Good morning John,
I have a song for you. It's actually for me, but I hope you like it anyway.
'Cos the universe is weird! I'm kinda freaking out!
What the heck is this all about?
Infinite unbounded sets and hadronizing gluon jets, and
We'll never understand half of what we have at hand. At least that's what I fear,
'Cos the universe is weird!
'Cos the universe is weird! I'm kinda freaking out!
What the heck is this all about?
Infinite unbounded sets and hadronizing gluon jets, and
We'll never understand half of what we have at hand. At least that's what I fear,
'Cos the universe is weird!
Yea the universe is weird! I'm kinda freaking out!
What the heck is this all about?
Infinite unbounded sets and hadronizing gluon jets, and
We'll never understand half of what we have at hand. At least that's what I fear,
'Cos the universe is weird!
Oh yea, oh it's so weird, it's so freaking weird!
Oh yea, the universe is weird!
The universe is weird!
Oh why on earth is the Earth so weird?
And the universe! Oh why in the universe is the universe so weird?
Oh it's kinda freaking me out
I don't know if you noticed, but
It's freaking freaking me out, it's so weird
Oh it's so weird.
Six quick announcements. First, this song is available and links in the description
either on Gumroad, which is pretty easy to use or iTunes, if they have uploaded it, which they haven't, as of the filming of this.
Second, John, for the very first time after 385 weeks on bookstore shelves, Looking for Alaska was on the New York Times' Bestseller List last week,
which is a really remarkable story for a book, and it's a really remarkable book so it deserves it, and if you, world, have not yet read the book,
it's becoming a classic, you should get it, there's a link in the description.
Third, I have seen a fair amount of DFTBA license plates in my time, but I now want to embark on a journey to collect all 50 of the states' DFTBA license plates,
so if you have one, or if you want to go get one, please send us a picture of it to hankandjohn@gmail.com.
Fourth, Alex Day made a freaking Nerdfighteria Sopio expansion. You can get it at a link in the description. There's a giraffe love card and a Hanklerfish.
Fifth, I have been on a songwriting spree lately, so I'm going to attempt to have the next four videos of mine have songs in them.
And sixth, Harry and the Potters and Potter Puppet Pals are going on a long tour and I'm going to be with them on three of those dates.
In Portland, Olympia, and Seattle. If you wanna see me on one of those days or them on any of those other dates,
you should go to the link in the description.
I hope that you're not overwhelmed by all of the links in the description. John, I will see you on Tuesday.